[Musik]
schönen guten abend bei bild die
richtigen fragen in einer situation wie
wir sie seit jahrzehnten in europa nicht
hatten an der schwelle zu einem großen
krieg aktuell in diesen minuten in
diesen stunden
militärmanöver machtdemonstration auf
russischer seite und dramatische szenen
gleichzeitig in der ost ukraine die uns
heute unser bild reporter paul
ronzheimer von dort an der front
mitgebracht hat er selbst ist zeuge
davon geworden musste durch die gräben
hindurch rein in den bunker schutz
suchen denn der beschuss hat dort
deutlich zugenommen diese bilder stammen
von ihm heute früh paul ronzheimer der
uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet ist in der
ost ukraine an der front mit uns
diskutieren wird und mit diesen
hochkarätigen gästen nämlich mit ukraine
botschafter andrej melik mit dem
langjährigen us botschafter john
kornblum der uns zugeschaltet ist
außerdem bei uns manfred weber der chef
der konservativen im eu-parlament und
von der spd der im auswärtigen ausschuss
sitzt ralf stegner schönen guten abend
dann alle herr botschafter herr wenig
wie dicht stehen wir aktuell vor allem
großen krieg
ich glaube dass unsere
fingerspitzen schon wirklich vor diesem
schrecklichen abgrund des neuen großen
krieges stehen
das gefühl ist
unterirdische auch bei meinen freunden
jetzt zu hause in kiew in der ukraine
die menschen haben eine große angst dass
das boot in diesen krieg tatsächlich
jetzt in den nächsten tagen vom zaun
bricht und deswegen muss man gerade
jetzt so lange es noch nicht zu spätes
handeln und deswegen möchte ich auch
wieder an die bundesregierung
appellieren an unsere freunde im westen
es ist jetzt an der seite dass man
tatsächlich diese präventiven maßnahmen
einleitet dass man die sanktionen
endlich beschließen bevor bevor der
beschuss von käfer stattfindet bevor
zivilisten zu tor bekommen das ist jetzt
das gebot der stunde und ich möchte auch
mich an die deutsche öffentlichkeit
wenden mit der bitte helfen sie uns
gehen sie bitte auf die straße ich
appelliere an die kirche wir brauchen
das gebet für den frieden es sind
wirklich die stunden wo es um krieg oder
frieden geht und da müssen wir alle
gemeinsam handeln die diplomatie hat
noch eine letzte chance obwohl das
fenster der möglichkeiten immer enger
wird das fenster wird er mehr länger das
sind dramatische worte vom botschafter
der ukraine an uns alle auch hier in
deutschland herr kornblum als
langjähriger us-botschafter wie groß ist
dieses fenster die diplomatie schon oder
ist es im grunde zumindest aus putin
sicht schon dicht schon geschlossen
das kann man nicht wissen weil putin hin
und her schwebt manchmal ist ja etwas er
gesprächsbereit und einmal nicht so wie
ich kann mich nur anschließen was
ehrlich gesagt hat da wir nicht wissen
was punkten eigentlich vorhat und wenn
er einen krieg anfangen würde wäre das
für auch russland vor allem eine große
katastrophe aber da will das nicht wir
sind müssen wir natürlich alle uns auf
das sozusagen schlimmste ergeben dass
vorbereiten und wir müssen solidarisch
bleiben wir müssen russland unter druck
setzen wir müssen auch militärische
hilfe an ukraine liefern und vor allem
wir müssen klarstellen dass wir auf der
westlichen seite auch die demokratie in
ukraine unterstützen und begrüßen dass
das keine auch einen teil der westlichen
welt werden will herr stegner kann man
jetzt schon sagen dass zumindest das
treffen von olaf scholz neulich mit
wladimir putin offenbar überhaupt keine
wirkung richtung deeskalation gebracht
hat wie man das zunächst vermutet hat
oder gehofft hatte das hat keine
deeskalation gebracht nein das kann man
nicht sagen sondern ich glaube dass es
nach wie vor darum gehen muss alle
möglichkeiten der diplomatie zu nutzen
dazu nutzt jedes gespräch gespräch die
orders ausgeführt hat die gespräche
geführt hat die
gespräche sind beiden führt aber warum
das gerade im nato-russland-rat passiert
das nützt alles was konkret weil er in
kurzen vermuten sie dass oder es ist
nicht erkennbar danach hat es eine
weitere eskalation gegeben die manöver
weise die wir gerade gesehen haben bei
diplomatie ist es immer so dass das
etwas ist das man mit geduld betrachten
muss und wo ich uns auch natürlich nicht
alle ergebnisse öffentlich werden ich
glaube das ist wichtig ist das westliche
bündnis einig es sind wir nach allem was
ich weiß gibt es da große klarheit dass
wir einig sind darin und das in
diplomatischen gesprächen der russischen
seite sehr deutlich gemacht wird das ist
eine große konsequenz für sie hätte wenn
russland den krieg eröffnen würde ich
nicht ganz sicher ob das angekommen ist
die botschaft herr weber als chef der
konservativen im eu-parlament andrej
melik hat dass gerade der ukrainische
botschafter ganz klar gemacht er sagt
wir müssen das jetzt beschließen wir
müssen diese aktion jetzt beschließen
damit eben keine weitere eskalation
eintritt worauf wartet europa
zumindest müssen wir die rechnung ganz
klar auf den tisch legen und daran
hapert es in europa immer neue wagen ist
im wahlkampf seine hände sind etwas
gebunden wenn man so formuliert und olaf
scholz hat es bisher nicht fertig
gebracht die nordstream zwei frage
wirklich klar zu thematisieren auch
washington immer wieder formulierungen
verwandt die zu unsicherheit eingeladen
der westen macht er keine geschlossenen
eindruck und das ist das größte problem
das wir haben es laut putin geradezu ein
jetzt voranzugehen und deswegen aus
unserer sicht dass sich der bürgerlichen
im europäischen parlament müsse man die
rechnung klar präsentieren das heißt
erstens nach dem 2 steht nicht mehr zur
debatte sollte es zur eskalation kommen
zwei ausschluss des bankensystems
russlands aus dem westlichen
finanzsystemen und die vorschläge von
boris johnson gestern auf der
sicherheitskonferenz sind da richtig
platziert und das dritte wir müssen
russland von der hochtechnologie
abschneiden und wenn wir das ernsthaft
und glaubwürdig wladimir putin
vermitteln dann weiß er dass der preis
hoch wird das europa ist noch nichts
passiert herr weber sie haben boris
johnson kader angesprochen die vielen
einmal zeigen was er bei der bbc für
eine eindringliche warnung abgegeben hat
ich muss leider sagen dass der plan den
wir sehen vom ausmaß her etwas ist das
wirklich der größte krieg in europa seit
1945 sein könnte ich muss leider sagen
dass der plan den wir sehen vom ausmaß
her etwas essen und das wirklich der
größte krieg in europa seit 1945 sein
könnte
übertreibt er hierher kondom oder ist
das tatsächlich das szenario ist uns
allen bewusst sein muss in diesen
minuten in diesen stunden
na da übertreibt nicht werden puten tut
was er meint dass er bereit ist zu
machen dann dass wir ohne frage der
grösste krise europas seit 1945 und auch
ein krieg der weitreichende konsequenzen
haben würde
franz albrecht will ich mit ins gespräch
reinziehen du warst heute den ganzen tag
unterwegs an der front und wir wollen
uns zunächst anschauen was du dort für
eindrücke mitgebracht hast also aus der
ost ukraine
es ist sonntagmorgen bild reporter paul
ronzheimer unterwegs in der ost ukraine
dort an der front spricht er gerade mit
ukrainischen soldaten über eine
russische invasion als geschosse
einschlagen
mörserbeschuss ganz in der nähe
lasst uns lieber in deckung
immer wieder neue einschläge laut hörbar
die soldaten geben jetzt das zeichen
schnell schutz suchen uns jetzt hier mit
meinen daten
also durch die gräben hindurch ab in den
nächsten bunker
gerade eben hat es hier direkt an
unserer position nur wenige hundert
meter entfernt einstiege gegeben und wir
mussten dann mit den ukrainischen
soldaten hier in untergrund sozusagen in
ihr versteck um uns vor weiteren
möglichen attacken von pro russischer
seite zu schützen das was wir hier
erleben gerade in diesem moment passiert
hier jeden tag und jede nacht zu und die
ukrainische soldaten wissen nie wann
gegen sie geschossen wird waren sie
angegriffen werden nach einigen minuten
etwas durchatmen paul ronzheimer fragt
andré der mit seinen 23 jahren für die
ukraine kämpft ob ihm die tausenden
russischen panzer diese riesige armee
denn gar keine angst macht
keine sorge wir haben panzer und guter
ausrüstung aber wir werden die hier
stoppen wir haben keine angst
und weiter durch die ost ukraine mit dem
schaukelnden auto vorbei an häusern mit
frischen kriegs spuren dieses darf nach
einem granatenanschlag zerstört nur
dürftig wird jetzt das loch gestopft im
eiskalten winter
und wieder geht es an der front entlang
dort wo immer beschuss droht auch hier
leben menschen kinder
paul ronzheimer trifft katja vierfache
mama warum gehen sie nicht weg sie haben
doch vier kinder ich kann doch nirgendwo
anders hin nirgendwo wartet jemand auf
mich und glauben sie dass putin sich
längst zum krieg entschieden hat fragt
paul ronzheimer
klar das hat er schon lange entschieden
wir haben gerade mit jemandem auf der
russischen seite gesprochen die haben
jetzt die generalmobilmachung verkündet
und alle frauen und kinder müssen raus
und die warten jetzt gerade in bussen an
der russischen grenze die sind geschockt
das sind beeindruckende stimme
beeindruckte bilder die du uns da heute
mitgebracht hast am heutigen tag aus der
ost ukraine wie weit bist du aktuell
entfernt von den atelier stellungen der
russen
ich bin in konstantinov keiner stadt in
der region donetsk man weiß mittlerweile
donets ist die stadt die 2014
eingenommen wurde von russen und von
separatisten gemeinsam muss man sagen
wir sind wenige kilometer hier von
dieser front entfernt und das
gefährliche an dieser front ist dass sie
eben durch dörfer geht und da sind viele
zivilisten die nicht weggehen wollen
weil sie nicht wissen wohin sie sollen
und man hört hier den ganzen tag und
auch gestern nach die ganze zeit
einschläge so viele einschläge wie es
zuletzt
2015/2016 gegeben hat täuscht der
eindruck oder reicht der moment einen
funken um eben ein ganzes feuer zu
entfachen
das ist das was putin ganz
offensichtlich will dass es auch das was
uns ukrainische soldaten sagen sie sagen
dass man sie bewusst provozieren will
also dass man von russischer seite
ukrainische stellung angreift um eine
reaktion zu provozieren und dann sagen
zu können die ukraine haben uns
angegriffen und jetzt brauchen wir die
gesamte russische armee das ist das was
man glaubt was hier passieren könnte das
ist das was auch der präsident bruno
mars ii lenz geht zu mir gesagt hat in
dieser woche dass man deshalb ruhe
bewahren muss dass man nicht panisch
sein darf und dass vor allem die
ukrainischen soldaten die fassung
bewahren müssen nur du hast die bilder
gerade gesehen du hast gesehen wie wir
dort heute morgen waren das ist
natürlich sehr sehr schwierig wenn man
angegriffen wird herr kornblum jetzt
sagt paul ronzheimer muster ruhe
bewahren auf keinen fall in panik
geraten gleichzeitig haben wir gerade in
der runde schon über eine klare
botschaft an putin gesprochen warum nach
all den wochen gibt es bisher keine
klare botschaft wie erklären sie das
naja ich glaube es gibt mindestens aus
den staaten gibt es eine sehr klare
botschaft
und puten weiß ganz genau woran er ist
er weiß aber auch welche kalkulationen
der macht und für ihn ist
mindestens das gefühl von bedrohung
nicht nur in ukraine soll auch im westen
wahrscheinlich ein wichtiges ziel ich
glaube wir müssen ein bisschen ruhe
bewahren nicht
unbedingt in der debatte mit putin
sondern unter uns selbst warum es sich
hier handelt es handelt sich nicht um
die erweiterung von nato es handelt sich
nicht um eine bedrohung für russland
sondern es handelt sich um genau die
entwicklung wofür die eu gegründet
worden ist das heißt die ausweitung der
demokratie in allen richtungen in europa
und putin hat angst nicht unbedingt vor
deutschen oder amerikanischen oder
ukrainischen streitkräfte sondern er hat
angst vor der demokratie
und wenn wir das verstehen und wir
verstehen wie wichtig es ist dass
ukraine auch zu uns als demokratisches
land auch hingehört dann werden wir auch
natürlich die ziele und auch die taktik
für diese konfrontation besser verstehen
im moment herrscht putin die debatte
muss man sagen muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen er ermittle seit mindestens acht
jahren an ein argument das sagt der
westen bedroht ihn russland muss sich
verteidigen das könnte nicht anders sein
der westen bedroht ihnen und dadurch
dass der westen offen und frei ist und
dass ukraine auch einen teil der freien
westen sein will das ist aber unser ziel
und das ist keine bedrohung und das soll
auch keine für russland überhaupt
kein problem bilden aber punkte will
natürlich keiner demokratie er will
keine offenheit der keine freiheit und
deshalb ist die ukraine für ihn
tatsächlich einen mindestens politische
und psychologische bedrohung die
demokratie ist die bedrohung für
wladimir putin herr mählich warum es der
eu warum es uns auch in deutschland
offenbar ja nicht ausreichend gelungen
putin abzuschrecken sowie das in der
zeit des kalten krieges war dass man
sich da eben ja als feinde gegenüber
stand aber offenbar
ist diese abschreckung bisher nicht
gelungen gegenüber putin warum
eine gute frage dass das was wir heute
haben wir haben zumindest also die
breite einigkeit innerhalb der eu auch
des westlichen blogs aber auf der
anderen seite fällt es eben an diese
abschreckung es fehlt an sehr sehr
robusten präventiven strafmaßnahmen
gegenüber russland und darum geht es
heute wir müssen jetzt endlich handeln
und wenn wir hören von den
amerikanischen freunden dass diese
angriffe schon wie möglich in den
nächsten tagen beginnen sollte dann dann
sollte man schon eigentlich oder hätte
man schon gestern oder vorgestern dieser
präventiven strafmaßnahmen herr
botschafter kornblum hatte diese auch
genannte sowie herr weber das heißt wir
müssten ähnliche morgen spätestens es
gibt ein radler in brüssel der eu
aussenminister mein minister wird morgen
auch dabei sein und berichten über die
lage und das ist vielleicht die letzte
chance der diplomatie mit
einigen maßnahmen die sofort eingeführt
werden müssen gegen russland und dann
schrift aber schrittweise schauen also
wenn es keine wirkung erzeugt dann
müssen die weiteren maßnahmen folgen das
ist die logik die die auch herr putin
verstehen wird alles andere wird nur als
eine beschwichtigungspolitik als
argumente verstehen das hat gestern auch
mein präsident in münchen hier ganz klar
gesagt sie sind dafür herr melnik sie
sind ebenfalls dafür dass jetzt auf den
tisch zu legen hat kornblum sie fordern
dass herr weber und sie stehen dem
moment entgegen herr stegner und der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz warum müsste
man nicht ganz klar benennen wenn die
antwort noch nicht angekommen ist bei
wladimir putin das sind diese aktion und
die greifen jetzt zum einen möchte ich
kann man darauf hinweisen dass das was
herr weber gesagt hat im widerspruch zu
dem steht was seine eigene partei
vorsitzende herr söder sagt großer merz
sagt also sogar einig sind die
konservativen offenbar auch nicht ich
klar sagen der alten wagen ganz kurzem
hatte ich sofort zu ihnen zurück nur das
sollte gerade handynummer ich sagen dass
mich dann schwierig wird wenn b herrn
merz und herrn söder sprechen hier geht
es um wirklich prima zitiert und ich
darf wieder sprechen weil ich
wahrgenommen habe was ändern was wenn
wir jetzt öffentlich gesagt das ist ein
widerspruch zu dem was er weiß aber
unbeschadet dessen gibt es eine klare
botschaft ich glaube nicht dass es darum
geht interview kriege zu führen sondern
dass es darum geht eine glasklare
botschaft zu geben die hat es in allen
gesprächen gegeben und die lage selbst
zu eskalieren indem man sozusagen
vorhersagt das passiert passiert genau
dieses öffentlich das ist nicht
besonders klug abschreckung funktioniert
er dadurch dass der gegner auch ein
stück im ungewissen gelassen wird und
man nicht öffentlich darlegen und
schritt eins zwei oder drei passiert
sondern dass man sehr deutlich macht
welche konsequenzen es haben alle
gemacht französischer präsident der
deutsche bundeskanzler der britische
premier amerikanische präsident in allen
gesprächen ist das dip und klar gesagt
worden wir wissen nicht was passiert was
wir aber wissen ist das ist eine
militärische auseinandersetzung in
europa kann es zufall wäre für die
zivilbevölkerung und es hätte ich würde
keine gewinner gehen bisher muss alles
unternommen werden diplomatischen das zu
verhindern genau das tun wir einigkeit
in der sache und klarheit dass man das
in der diplomatie versucht das finde ich
sehr viel schlauer als ich öffentlich
juli zu liefern wenn ich ihnen an einem
punkt widersprechen darf weil sie vorhin
gesagt haben früher hatte man sich als
feinde gegenüber gestanden die
abschreckung funktioniert das ziel kann
nicht sein sich als feinde gegenüber zu
stehen das kann nicht unser ziel sein
sondern wir brauchen eine sicherheit die
ganze in europa nur geben als gemeinsame
sicherheit auch mit russen ja das ist
ziemlich egal möglicherweise auch dass
unser ziel ist wenn da zehntausende
hunderttausende soldaten direkt an der
grenze stehen und eben eine bedrohung
eine zunehmende bedrohung darstellen für
die ukraine dann fällt einem das wort
freund erstmal nicht so richtig ein herr
stegner sind sie denn überzeugt davon
olaf scholz hinter den kulissen ganz
klar die karten auf den tisch gelegt hat
denn der eindruck entsteht ja nicht man
sagt nur nicht was dann genau passiert
also man benennt nicht ganz klar die
szenarien sondern man weiß doch gar
nicht ganz genau was da passiert weil
man sich in europa nämlich gar nicht
hundertprozentig einig ist weil sie
nämlich vor allen dingen bremsen und
sich eben nicht klar bekennen sogar das
ist doch überhaupt entschuldung sie das
ist so eine behauptung daran stimmt doch
nichts ist dies alles ist auf dem tisch
jamaikanischen präsident hat klipp und
klar gesagt es ist da keinerlei
unterschiede mit der bundesregierung
gehe und dass die behauptung aufgestellt
werden wir sein da nicht eigentlich
falsch sind ich glaube nur dass der
unterschied darin besteht dass wir der
meinung sind dass die einzige
möglichkeit die diplomatie ist wir
hatten weder was von graphen lieferung
noch davon die sache selbst zu
eskalieren sondern es muss haben
diplomatie gehen militärisch kann der
konflikt nicht gelöst sein und darf er
nicht gelöst werden das muss mit aller
macht versucht werden und da muss der
westen einig sein nach allem was ich
weiß ist er das ich kenne keine andere
informationen hat sich weber anderen
formationen kennt alles was wir hören
ist dass es bei allen gesprächen der
verbündeten einigkeit gibt und
deutschland ist teil davon wenn man kann
ich das ausdrücklich an die adresse
deutschlands gesagt und sie haben
darüber im bundestag debattiert am
freitag es gibt da keine unterschiede
nur ist auch nochmal öffentlich sich
radikal zu äußern nützt gar nichts es
war ein block weder herrn putin doch hat
es irgendeinen sinn un sanktionen in
kraft zu setzen
bevor er sozusagen was militärisch
passiert ist hat davon halte ich ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht im übrigen will immer
sagen die lage in ausdrucken ist schon
seit jahren ein problem und der minsker
vertrag wird von beiden seiten leider
nicht eingehalten so etwas passiert es
hat der stegner gerade gesagt paul
ronzheimer es ist natürlich schon eine
menge passiert und passiert zunehmend
was dort im grenzgebiet an der front
[Musik]
das ist richtig hier passiert jeden tag
etwas und es ist weitaus schlimmer
geworden als es in den vergangenen
jahren war ich war immer wieder hier
seid 2014 und es stimmt was ralf stegner
sagt dass da eben schon eine invasion
stattgefunden hat nur man muss ganz klar
sagen auch da hat die spd gebremst frank
walter steinmeier damals außenminister
hat sich einlullen lassen von wladimir
putin hat sich immer wieder sagen lassen
ja wenn wir mit putin nicht hart umgehen
werden wenn wir keine scharfen
sanktionen machen dann wird das schon
irgendwie besser werden denn man muss
man eines ganz klar sagen 2014 gab es
anders als behauptet wir für die
annexion der krim oder den krieg in
nahost und keine eben keine harten
sanktionen die oligarchen konnten weiter
fliegen nach deutschland nach london
überall hin und ihren urlaub machen und
haben mit den gas milliarden am ende
diesen krieg erst finanziert und die spd
hat es möglich gemacht dass durch nord
stream 2 und durch das was putin
eingenommen hat am ende jetzt hier die
ukraine umzingelt wird von panzern und
tausende zivilisten drohen zu sterben
wenn wladimir putin ihr den befehl gibt
also bei aller liebe dies nicht die spd
hat ja etwas möglich macht sanktionen
werden in europa gemeinsam beschlossen
nicht von der spd so von allen ländern
gemeinde punkt eins und die regierung
daher
gemeinsam
ich rede von frank walter steinmeier
herr stegner ich jede von frank walter
steinmeier der damals außenminister war
ich habe mich beginnt
so hätte vermittelt in der regierung
merkel das ist richtig ja ich in dem
frau merkel da auch nicht aus aber das
war eben ein riesenfehler der begangen
worden ist und wenn man jetzt sagen na
da haben sich schon auf den tischen
sanktionen optionen auf dem tisch dann
muss man sich doch fragen warum sollte
putin sie denn jetzt ernst nehmen hat er
die letzten jahre ja auch nicht müssen
herr weber ganz kurz ganz kurz
dazwischen jetzt sehen wir heute dass
eine weitere verabredung nicht
eingehalten wurde von putin der will es
nämlich seiner soldaten in weißrussland
um weitere manöver durchzuführen ist das
der punkt eben um sanktionen jetzt
durchzusetzen dass er sich auch an diese
verabredung nicht hält zu bisherigen
debatten nur einen satz die spd muss
sich dringend von der alten schröder spd
emanzipieren das ist genau die botschaft
und darüber nach wie vor unsicherheit
der sozialdemokratie das leider gottes
von putin er als einladung gesehen wird
das noch mal zur bisherigen debatte und
zur zukunft sie haben recht putin hat
bereits einiges erreicht belarus da
hatten wir vor ein paar monaten noch
mutige menschen auf der straße die
demonstriert haben wir freiheit für
demokratie für ein rechtsstaat und heute
ist belarus fest in russischer hand
lukaschenko ist eine marionette des
kreml geworden und es werden gemeinsame
manöver durchgeführt ein land wo die
bereits integriert in russisches in die
russische neue empire sozusagen und
jetzt ist die ukraine dran und was soll
sich bitte nichts vormachen auch wir
dürfen uns als deutsches oder planeten
die in die komfortzone zurückziehen wenn
putin in der ukraine erfolg hat dann
wird seine attacken gegen den westen
weiter gehen er hat auf deutschem grund
und boden schon morde verübt in
tiergarten beispielsweise er attackiert
unseren deutschen bundestag mit cyber
angriffen aus russischen netzwerken
heraus und di maria weber die frage nach
der neuen verabredung nach all den
börsen passiert ist die putin wieder
gebrochen hat nämlich dass er eben die
truppen da aus zu den manövern aus
weißrussland nicht abzieht sondern
weitere manöver abhalten will ist das
der punkt das ist der punkt und es zeigt
dass die belarussischen macht habe heute
schon keine verantwortung mehr im land
tragen sondern das in kreml entschieden
wird wie es dort weitergeht also die
einflusszone auszuweiten hatte putin
bereits in diesen bereichen erreicht
übrigens eher kleinigkeiten nur aber für
mich wichtiger punkt alexej nawalny
jemand der in russland für demokratie
und der rechtsstaat und der freiheit
eintritt wurde jetzt für weitere 15
jahre eingesperrt sein sollte denn das
schaudepot demokratie und demokratie und
freiheit einzusperren wegzug erkern in
russland das das genau der punkt ist ich
sagte so eindrücklich weil ich manchmal
sorge bei uns in deutschland dass wir
das sagen was geht uns das an das ist so
weit weg und all die themen ich werbe
dafür es ist unsere aufgabe jetzt an der
seite die ukraine zu stehen weil sie
ankommt kämpfen der auch unser kommt ist
nicht gerade unsere werte geht eine
frage noch mal ganz konkret herr weber
welche st zu und boris jones in dem
gespräch dass wir eben gerade ganz kurz
ausschnittweise gezeigt haben sagt er
auch russische firmen sollten keinen
zugang zu dollar um fund haben ist das
eine mögliche sanktion zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt
ich unterstütze boris johnson weil es
entschiedenheit der westlichen
gemeinschaft zeigen würde wenn wir jetzt
handeln und ich habe vorher beim
einstieg bereits die drei punkte
besprochen ersten dass die
gaslieferungen aus dem zwei bankensystem
und das dritte hochtechnologie dies sind
die drei felder die putin wirklich ernst
nimmt und da sollten wir entschieden
sein die sollten wir jetzt benennen
nicht um einen herum auch wenn sie ganz
konkret die frage was ist die eine
sanktion also aus europäischer sicht die
wir eben auf diese ja diplomatischen
harten mittel dann noch setzen können
wenn wir nicht die militärische stärke
haben wie die amerikaner welche eine
sanktionen könnte putin jetzt zum
einlenken bringen
es gibt eine menge natürlich die ich bin
sehr dafür was herr angst und sagte aber
man darf nicht vergessen dass
großbritannien
sehr günstige angebote hat an russischen
oligarchen in letzten jahren dazu leben
und sehr viel geld zu verdienen es gibt
das so genannte swift system das ist die
weltweite
zahlungsmöglichkeit ein zahlungssystem
das
russland sehr sehr schaden würde aber
wenn hier ist ein punkt den ich machen
wollte demokratien haben es schwieriger
als autoritären regierungen weil sie
auch eine innenpolitik haben und sie
müssen auch auf diese innenpolitik
achten und die
umfragen zeigen dass in europa auf
deutschland aber über an europa aber
auch in den vereinigten staaten viele
menschen die mehrheit der befragten
sagen was geht uns das an ihnen das ist
irgendwas ganz weit weg in russland oder
wer weiß was wichtig ist für uns dass
wir nicht nur die sanktionen jetzt
darstellen ich bin sehr dafür ich finde
es etwas witzig sogar dass man sagt ja
wir werden böse sachen tun wenn du uns
tötet aber wenn du uns nicht schuldet
dann werden wir nichts tun sollten das
machen bevor er die menschen wasser
stecken sagt finden sie witzig
finde es sehr witzig und ich finde auch
sehr traurig dass er stehen also eine
meinung hat und das ist auch der grund
warum deutschland aber vor allem die spd
als unsicheren kantonisten in der gruppe
gesehen wird er steckte sie können das
alles schwer ablehnen wenn sie wollen
aber die tatsache dass ist die tatsache
jetzt ein schuldenfreies können wir
können wir das archiv von von putins
tagen hört zurückholen
dreistigkeit auch die sanktionen aber
auch ist auch dass wir anfangen zu
erklären warum das so ist und das wird
es nicht zulassen zu sagen dass wir das
alles gestiftet haben durch die
erweiterung der nato oder dazu für
investitionen nur einfach ist aber nicht
machen sucht dieser jetzige krise in
2014 hat nichts mit der nato zu tun
sondern mit einem handelsabkommen das
die eu keine abschließen wollte das
zeigt dass die angst in russland oder in
putin ist nicht unbedingt die nato
sondern es ist sozusagen die westliche
orientierung von keine eine orientierung
dass wir alle im westen ja sie gern
begrüßen würden herr stegner ihre
antwort drei dinge gerne sagen erstens
es gibt kein land das die ukraine
stärker unterstützen wirtschaftlicher
als die bundesrepublik deutschland
als deutschland ganz klar öffentlich
gesagt hat aldi konnte mit einer reihe
mit den problemen die wir da hatten wir
der deutschen welle clique angesprochen
und drittens auch wenn der biber
versucht hast du den parteipolitischen
punkt hier zu machen was die menschen
über uns gar nicht hilft würde ich
darauf aufmerksam machen dass die
sanktionen gemeinsam von europäischen
union beschlossen gemeinsam alle
sanktionen gemeinsam müssen wir hätten
anders gibt es nämlich an die sanktion
sollte jemand wissen der fraktion ja nur
noch etwas gegen die spd dann werden
diese man nur weiß und lagen und mal
passiert gemein weil sonst könnten wir
ja passieren wenn sie nicht auf der
bremse stehen dass mit der jetzt in der
runde hier auch deutlich sie sind
derjenige der sagt nicht jetzt auf den
tisch legen alle anderen sagen jetzt auf
den tisch legen und zwar kontakte sagt
sie sind auf den tisch gelegt worden
aber in der diplomatische hinter
diplomatie oder sie nicht mehr
interviews und vor kameras naja andere
diplomaten sind wir hier in der runde
ein langjähriger diplomatische und
kornblum ein aktiver diplomat andrej
melik die streifen in volkswagen gehören
das sagen nicht einmal was jetzt gerade
eingeführt aber wir können einen punkt
noch raus greift nämlich die vorgeworfen
ich bin heute von estnischen kollegen
angesprochen worden warum gibt die
berlin jetzt das hat nichts mit merkel
zu tun hat nichts mit der union zu tun
ist auch einige jetzige amtierende
regierungsentscheidung warum gibt man
nicht grünes licht für das liefern von
estnischen waffen die aus alten nva
beständen bestehen das wird in der welt
genommen also eine verweigerung
deutschlands dass man eben die ukraine
nicht zur seite stehen reagieren sie
sagen woran es gelegen hat und man sich
halt direkt an bord zu gehen heute auch
in branchen wie die verwandten der
situation gar nichts im übrigen auch die
amerikanische seite nicht dass der
konflikt militärisch entschieden werden
könnte oder sollte sondern das
verhindert werden muss dass es dazu
kommt und dass wir harte sanktionen
vereinbaren für den fall dass es anders
kommt aber mit waffen die vor etwas zu
verändern militärs das findet nicht mehr
die amerikanische seite richtig und die
deutsche wurde ist es nicht wahr
verschiedene nicht nur dem wagen der
modelle legend liegt es stimmt nicht
waffenlieferungen sind ja erst jetzt
eine starke solidarität bei beistands
bekundung und ich denke dass das genau
das zeichen des deswegen haben die us
amerikaner ja auch so umfangreich waffen
geliefert und wir haben eine große
wirtschaftliche unterstützung geleistet
das ist die solidaritäts bekomme noch
ausgeweitet sagt nochmal mit waffen
herum herrscht eben nicht verstecken ein
haken ja herr stegner
darf ich einen haken ja also danke für
ihre these für die hilfe also diese
hilfe ist etwas so was wir heute
benötigen also wie heute brauchen wir
nicht nur ihre schönen worte nicht nur
diese solidarischen bekundungen wir
brauchen waffen für die verteidigung und
diese waffen die deutschen liefern
könnte sie diese waffen werden uns nach
wie vor verweigert sogar die niederlande
die auch eine ähnliche position hatten
sie haben vor wenigen tagen ihre meinung
geändert und liefern gerade jetzt die
defensiv war von an die ukraine deswegen
ich kann hier nur folgendes sagen es ist
eine kleine schöne ausrede jetzt sich zu
berufen darauf aus deutschland vor acht
jahren getan hat dass man sein wir
schätzen diese hilfe aber im moment ist
gefordert dass das grüne wirklich in die
lage gebracht werden also widerstand zu
leisten wären morgen britische truppen
tatsächlich eingreifen sollten und
deswegen es kommt jetzt darauf an uns zu
stärken die menschen warten auf diese
unterstützung und ich kann ihnen
folgendes sagen wenn deutschland sich
nach wie vor oder weiterhin weigern wird
und wenn putin tatsächlich in den
nächsten tagen oder wochen einmarschiert
das würde bedeuten das versagen der
deutschen außenpolitik das wäre eine
bankrotterklärung ihre politik und die
ukraine werden diesen verrat nie
vergessen das sind harte worte
das heißt wenn es zu der invasion zu dem
einmarsch kommt sind sie schuld mit herr
stegner sagt er wenig bei allem respekt
herr botschafter ersten zehn milliarden
hilfen kann schön wurde so sehen so weit
die ukraine streiten ich möchte ihnen
diese botschaft ausharrt weiterleiten
verbot scharf an sie und an die ampel
regierten verbot schafft daher nicht
dass auch zu ende führen darf jetzt die
ausreden lassen wenn man der festen
überzeugung ist es der konflikt
militärisch geführt und entschieden
werden kann sind waffenlieferungen
jedenfalls nicht der richtige weg und
wird deutschland das auch nicht wählen
liefern keine waffen in spannungsgebiete
auch nicht die ukraine sollen wir tun
alles um sie liefern alles um eine
gemeinsame seit jahren rund in
krisengebiete und heftigen hatte
eigentlich noch kein zeuge nach ägypten
diese frage hat wenn wir nacheinander
regen ich kann mir nichts das ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen wenn sie das wie
die deutsche öffentlichkeit diesen
diesen krieg und das schlafen der
griechen zivilisten jetzt live vor augen
sehen wirte weil es wird ein krieg sein
also verlauf und der kamera und wenn sie
sehen dass die ukraine hätten sich
verteidigen können und sie haben das
unterlassen dass eine unterlassene
hilfeleistung und sogar im deutschen
recht ist das eine straftat herr stegner
deswegen ich möchte sie wirklich daran
erinnern dass solidarität heißt nicht
nur schöne worte zu sagen oder daran zu
erinnern dass die ukraine diese hilfe
bekommen hat das schätzen wir aber das
ist leider zu wenig was sie konnte ich
bin nicht der einzige in der runde
gehabt ist der konflikt nicht
militärisch gelöst werden kann aber das
ist jedenfalls meine position darum geht
sie brauchen sie nicht zu korrigieren
lassen lieber mit dem favoriten um die
verteidigung das wird das als entlastung
uns die rote linie möchte keinen kriegen
herr weber ganz kurze frage bevor wir
hier einmal kurz durchschnaufen eine
kurze pause machen das sagt andrej melik
der botschafter der ukraine er sagt wenn
es zu dem militärischen konflikt jetzt
kommt wenn es zu dem einmarsch kommt zur
invasion kommt wenn putin ernst macht
dann trägt die bundesregierung dafür
wesentliche verantwortung der verrat wie
er es nennt sie das
putin versteht nur die sprache der
stärke der macht das ist dass putin
versteht und diese sprache sprechen wir
derzeit nicht ich würde übrigens
durchaus weitergehen nicht nur wir
deutschen nicht sondern die europäer
insgesamt nicht wir sind auf die stürme
die in dieser welt da draußen auf uns
auf uns warten nicht vorbereitet und wir
sollten auch ganz ehrlich sein wir
können uns derzeit zurücklehnen weil wir
den amerikanischen schutzschirm haben
wir können das aus dem fernsehen und aus
dem internet beobachten weil die
amerikanische schutzschirm wir haben
aber die ukraine können das nicht die
menschen dort wollen so lieben wie wir
leben dürfen in freiheit demokratie aber
sie werden jetzt bedroht von jemanden
der das unterdrücken will und insofern
wir sind nicht vorbereitet und dort regt
berlin derzeit auch mit der unklaren
haltung vor allem bei den ostring 2 eine
schwere verantwortung danke für den
moment manfred weber chef der
konservativen von dem ziel verabschieden
diskutieren aber ansonsten gleich weiter
nach einer kurzen pause
[Musik]
zurück bei den richtigen fragen hier am
sonntagabend in einer ganz besonderen
situation nämlich an der schwelle zu
einem großen krieg in europa wollen wir
genau darüber diskutieren und das tun
wir jetzt im prominent darunter mit dem
ukrainischen botschafter andrej melik
mit dem langjährigen us botschafter john
kornblum mit ralf stegner von der spd
mit unserem reporter paul ronzheimer
dort an der front in der ost ukraine und
bei uns jetzt auch sergey lagodinsky der
für die grünen im europaparlament sitzt
und hier in der runde machte war gerade
ersetzt also sergey lagodinsky schönen
guten abend auch an sie wir hören immer
schülern und jetzt von ukrainischer
seite haben das am wochenende von der
sicherheitskonferenz gehört dass die
antwort auf die frage nach der nato
mitgliedschaft so sagt selensky doch
bitte ehrlich beantwortet werden soll
wie würde ihre antwort aktuell an herren
c lenz gegeben wenn er fragt wollt ihr
uns jetzt in der nato ja oder nein
ich glaube ehrlich gesagt das ja so
lansky nicht derjenige ist der jetzt
diese frage oder eine antwort verdient
sondern herr putin herr putin hat
gefragt und das ist die frage die wir
vorher gründlich beantworten müssen herr
putin hat gefragt ob wir ausschließen
können auch schriftlich und rechtsgültig
dass wir unsere ukrainischen partner
irgendwann in theater aufnehmen und
darauf ist die frage ganz klar nein das
werden wir nicht ausschließen alles
andere ist hypothetisch und es wäre aus
meiner sicht nicht zielführend wenn wir
in dieser aufgeheizten situation jetzt
nach dem politischen schaden und
hypothetischen antworten suchen na ja
aber das ist ja eine klare antwort nur
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere hat herr
stegner olaf scholz diese antwort ganz
anders gegeben er bei der
pressekonferenz nämlich und auch im
anschließenden statement gesagt na ja
also die ukraine werde sicherlich nicht
während seiner amtszeit zur nato gehören
also hat die frage genau umgekehrt
beantwortet
ja hätte ich habe es gesagt ist die
frage nicht auf der tagesordnung steht
das ist ja das was der kollege von den
grünen eben auch gesagt hat sie steht
nicht auf der tagesordnung und sich
militärisch auseinanderzusetzen über
fragen die gar nicht auf der
tagesordnung stehen ist glaube ich mit
das dümmste was passieren kann und
deswegen sage ich noch mal was nicht in
frage kommt ist das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker zu
verneinen und zu erklären dass es nicht
möglich ist aber es gehören immer zwei
dinge zu nämlich
jetzt meine frage meine antworten
aus meiner sicht aus meiner sicht muss
es auch klar sein dass wir nichts
ausschließen und dass wir für alles
offen sind übrigens nicht nur die nato
sondern und das ist meine priorität ganz
ehrlich ist da eine klare eu perspektive
für die ukraine muss bleiben es ist aber
muss man auch sagen weiter drittbeste
das haben wir bei georgien auch gesehen
da sind wir haben bisschen beitrag
gewesen aber es gibt einen roadmap es
gibt bestimmte ein bestimmter prozess
wie man in beide organisationen ein land
aufnimmt und das wird dauern und ich
glaube das ist das was herr scholz
gemeint hat es wird wahrscheinlich viel
länger dauern als er an der macht ist
meine hoffnung ist auch dass vielleicht
putin vorher die macht abgibt aber das
war ja der witz boden herrn scholz das
werden wir leider nicht selbst bestimmen
können ja wir versuchen immer zu
interpretieren die worte von olaf scholz
dann hätten sie offenbar klarer sein
müssen er wenig warum fordert nun ihr
präsident eine ehrliche antwort auf eine
frage die laut ralf stegner überhaupt
nicht auf der tagesordnung ist und dumm
ist jetzt auf die tagesordnung zu setzen
das habe ich nicht gesagt also wir
glauben dass
das der westen und auch deutschland
ehrlich sein müssen es gibt eine
entscheidung seit dem jahre 2008
der nato-mitgliedsstaaten wo es schwarz
auf weiß steht also die ukraine wird
nato-mitglieder sein und seitdem hat hat
sich kaum etwas getan da hat sich auch
die bundesregierung nichts unternommen
um die dieses ziel zu erreichen um der
ukraine zu helfen sicher anzunehmen das
wurde immer wieder verhindert politisch
und jetzt hören wir von der neuen
bundeskanzler dass solange er an der
macht ist dieses thema gar nicht
auf der tagesordnung bleibt und das ist
natürlich das hat für die menschen in
der ukraine gerade jetzt angesichts
dieser enormen
bedrohungen von russland verheerenden
auswirkungen und deswegen wir müssen
ehrlich miteinander umgehen und das hat
das war das was mein präsident gestern
hier in münchen auf der konferenz
gefordert hat wozu würdet euch denn herr
kornblum reiseführer wenn man jetzt
beispielsweise so ein moratorium machen
würde würde das putin nur einmal den
gedanken zu lassen dazu bringen jetzt
truppen zurückzuziehen aus weißrussland
vor allen dingen aus von den grenzen von
der ost ukraine
also wenn man jetzt moratorium machen
würde und sagen würde die nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahre kommt hier eine
nato-mitgliedschaft und hier ist die
unterschrift definitiv nicht in frage
nein natürlich nicht das wäre natürlich
sein großer wünschen dass wir den weg
frei machen um noch mehr druck auf die
ukraine zu machen hier müssen wir
verstehen ich habe da schon am anfang
gesagt es handelt sich hier nicht um die
nato und nicht um die
nato-mitgliedschaft es handelt sich hier
um die demokratie und ukraine und die
orientierung der der keine in westliche
richtung
er hat nämlich hat völlig recht voll
jetzt vor 14 jahre hat die nato so
gesagt dass die dazu keine ein mitglied
werden sollte an dieser schritt ist
schon genommen worden und es wäre noch
viel mehr passiert werden ehrlich gesagt
wenn die bundeswehr in deutschland das
liegt blockiert hätte aber es gibt auch
ein noch einen weiteren schritt den man
machen und eine sogenannte m a php
action programm das hat ist ein programm
um vorbereitung eines neuen mitglieds
auf die mitgliedschaft ohne irgendwelche
antworten ob diese mitgliedschaft oder
so möglich sein würde weil man ja sehen
ob das land bereit ist aber die zum
beispiel in letzter zeit ist die das
kleine die kleine republik waren tournee
glauben mitglied geworden und ich glaube
wenn man mitglied werden kann kann auch
ziemlich gut bestehen hier ist die frage
und die kette nur sehr kurz auf herrn
stehen dann zurückkommen
natürlich sind alle für eine
diplomatische lösung mit einer ausnahme
putin man sie wissen vielleicht ich war
sehr sehr aktiven im wahlkampf vor 20
jahren und ich habe persönlich 25 vier
augen sprechen mit milosevic gehabt er
sagte mir seine beste freundin waren die
europäer weil sie immer verschrieben
gesprochen haben wo sie hätten wissen
müssen dass ich ein krieg vorbereiten
das ist jetzt der punkt hier auch man
kann so lange wie sie können zum lager
für diplomatie und frieden reden wir
wollen genauso wie herr champion vor 80
jahren aber wenn die andere seite an
krieg haben möchte dieses gerede von
diplomatie und verhandelt doch jetzt
bringt wirklich nix paul ist nix nix zu
dir wir waren bei der frage nachgeht
mitgliedschaft wie ist dein eindruck im
moment direkt bei den soldaten dort an
der front rechnete irgendjemand auf
ukrainischer seite mit einer
nato-mitgliedschaft irgendwann am
horizont
nein diese nato mitgliedschaft ist
überhaupt kein thema bei den soldaten
keiner glaubt daran dass das so kommt
und viele verweisen auch darauf dass
genau das passiert es 2008 haben
deutschland und frankreich ist eben
verhindert man muss aber noch eins sagen
was hier sehr emotional diskutiert wird
in der ukraine immer wenn man dann sagt
ja dann soll putin doch eine garantie
geben und dann gehen wir da nicht rein
dann sagen alle na ja wir haben ja schon
mal einen vertrag mit ihm geschlossen
das war 1994 da haben wir hier in der
ukraine
da haben die ukraine ihre atomwaffen
abgegeben und habe sicherheitsgarantien
von russland und vom westen bekommt und
da sagen die soldaten da sagen die
menschen hier in der ukraine ja was
waren denn diese sicherheitsgarantien
wert jetzt sind wir umzingelt von putins
panzern wir haben uns atomwaffen
abgegeben wir haben das erfüllt und
jetzt stehen wir da über die
nato-mitgliedschaft da macht sich keiner
gedanken da sagt keiner das wird
funktionieren ich will ein wort noch
sagen zum präsidenten selensky das sind
durchaus unterschiedliche botschaften
die ja da setze ich war diese woche fast
36 stunden mit ihm unterwegs und hatte
ich ihn angesprochen habe nachts olaf
scholz druck auf sie dass sie die nato
mitgliedschaft nicht anstreben da hat er
sehr diplomatisch der antwort und er hat
gesagt na ja es ist sehr klar dass
einzelne mitgliedsstaat nicht wollen
dass wir in nato gehen und deswegen ist
das eigentlich kein thema weshalb ich
mich gewundert habe dass er das bei der
sicherheitskonferenz wieder zu einem
großen thema gemacht hat lagodinsky
heute gab es nochmal treffen von emanuel
makro und telefonat mit wladimir putin
die ganzen treffen in letzter zeit wenn
der kornblume jetzt sagt na ja wir
verhandeln da wir versuchen eine
diplomatische lösung jemandem der keine
diplomatische lösung bildern ist das ja
diese art von gespräch sinnlos wir
müssen ja in diesem sind nur zweigleisig
fahren und das ist ja klar dass sowohl
herr kompromiss auch gegner recht haben
wir brauchen diplomatie aber es ist ja
selbstverständlich dass diplomatie nicht
bedeutet dass wir erstens das opfer
schutzlos dastehen lassen da müssen ja
auch verschiedenen wege neben ukraine
unter die arme greifen und sich
solidarisch zeigen und zweitens dass wir
daraus auch lernen dass wir als nato
aber auch als deutschland eben nicht nur
auf diplomatie setzen können es gibt
situationen wo ist klar dass wir macht
projizieren müssen auch militärischer
macht oder jedenfalls klare deutliche
sanktion und wenn ich etwas kritisieren
würde an dieser bundesregierung obwohl
ich ja auch so gewissermaßen mit
beteiligt bin mit meiner partei mit
einer parteimitgliedschaft
ist dass wir die zeit versäumt haben wo
wir klar kommuniziert hätten nämlich
dieser eine pause wo herr scholz noch
nicht in moskau angekommen ist wo eben
auch leider muss man sagen aus der spd
unterschiedliche töne auch zunächst um
zwei gekommen sind wir sind aber über
diese phase hinaus und das muss man auch
anerkennen die spd steht hier ganz klar
auch bei der vater von moss 52 auch wenn
ich dieses harry potter spiel von
unserem kanzler nicht so ganz teile ich
bin der band dann können wir auch mal
sagen dass eben als auch der kanzler
kann sagen dass 92 auf dem tisch liegt
für den fall der aggression aber wenn
man mit allen spd menschen spricht und
verantwortliche spricht sagen sie das
ist doch ganz klar dass das ein teil des
sanktionspaket sein wird insofern finde
ich auch nicht
wir müssen jetzt auch klug sein ja und
ich bin bei waffenlieferungen bei
anderen fahren vielleicht auch etwas
einer anderen position als herr stegner
aber in dieser situation
die nato mitgliedschaft in die
diskussion einfach so nebenbei reihen zu
werfen und darauf zu bestehen dass wir
sofort eine antwort
präsentieren das ist finde ich
strategisch und taktisch auch sehr
gefährlich und es wird auch nicht
passieren dass irgendjemand ob das marco
scholz oder anderer sein werden diese
beiden nicht wir werden nicht sagen wir
werden ihre beine die ukraine muss man
sagen in die nato jetzt sofort aufnehmen
das ist ein prozess diese erwartungen
denn unrealistisch und da würde ich auch
unsere ukrainischen kolleginnen und
kollegen darum bitten strategien auch
für die kommunikation etwas klarer
heraus geboren hermetik die
kommunikation etwas klarer fest zu tun
und die kritik von herrn lagodinsky
richtung ihres präsidenten und auch in
ihre richtung ist jetzt deutlich
geworden wenn auch etwas verklausuliert
ich darf das alle meinen worten
übersetzen heißt mensch bitte jetzt
nicht gerade über die
nato-mitgliedschaft sprechen dass gießt
noch öl ins feuer das muss jetzt gerade
wirklich nicht sein
schauen sie also wir sind nicht
diejenigen die jetzt einen krieg wollen
also wir wollen dass der frieden
aufrecht erhalten bleibt wir wollen in
einem demokratischen land mitten in
europa leben aber wir wollen auch
natürlich zu dieser familien gehören zum
zu zur eu das ist eine große frage die
nach wie vor auf dem tisch bleibt und
auch da fehlt übrigens eine ähnliche
antwort
da könnte auch die bundesrepublik eine
führende rolle spielen um eben den weg
also für diese mitgliedschaft zu ebenen
und uns dabei zu helfen also die
skeptiker innerhalb der eu und es gibt
einige länder die natürlich auch sich
noch erweitern zu überzeugen also darum
geht es heute dass das die deutschland
dass deutschland das die bundesrepublik
diese führungsrolle über
und auch dasselbe gilt für die nato wir
wollen der nato beitreten weil wir teil
dieses
verteidigungsbündnisses werden möchten
wir wollen auch eigenen beitrag leisten
wir haben gezeigt dass die ukraine sehr
wohl fähig und willens ist für dieses
europa auch zu stehen und zu kämpfen das
sind keine hülsen keine leeren worte und
darum geht es geht darum dass das dass
da keine augenwischerei tag und nach
betrieben wird von unseren freunden hier
in der eu in der nato sondern dass wir
klare antworten bekommen auf unsere sehr
klaren fragen dazu gehörte auch
ehrlichkeit in bezug auf die
nato-botschafter kornblum hat gesagt wir
brauchen einen prozess es ist nicht an
einem tag kann das geschehen wir
brauchen diesen membership action plan
auf den weg zu bringen und ich da auch
deutschland also in die pflicht
botschafter ich will einmal ganz kurz
dieses thema aus der welt der diplomatie
rausholen aus der welt der anzüge und
krawatten die wir fast alle heute tragen
und reingehen zu den menschen die das
alles gerade aus baden und
möglicherweise noch noch viel mehr
ausbaden müssen es gibt ein ganz starkes
bild von den olympischen spielen in
peking dass wir uns einmal anschauen da
haben sich zwei sportler umarmt ein
russischer und ein ukrainischer sportler
wintersportler freestyler und danach gab
es heftige kritik auch von ihrer seite
von der ukrainischen seite das sei jetzt
wirklich nicht angezeigt da solle man
mehr professionalität mehr distanz
wahren lassen wenig was ist daran
schlimm wenn sich zwei menschen umarmen
ich glaube man muss das in einem
zusammenhang sehen und der zusammenhang
ist der dass wir gerade diese
schrecklichen bilder aus der ost ukraine
gesehen und klar ist dass russland für
diesen achtjährigen krieg verantwortung
trägt dass zehntausende menschen opfer
geworden sind das zwei millionen ukraine
fliehen mussten aus dem don was das ist
die realität seit acht jahren und
angesichts dieser lage und angesichts
dessen dass diese bedrohung jetzt noch
viel schlimmer geworden ist und dass wir
einen neuen riesigen krieg jetzt mitten
in europa befürchten müssen sind diese
bilder für für viele meiner landsleute
natürlich verstörende und deswegen bin
ich bei denen die sagen als sport muss
sein also wir sind froh dass ukrainische
athleten dass das unsere sportler auch
bei die olympier dabei waren aber wie
gesagt es geht darum dass das russland
von heute heutige russland womöglich
einen neuen einmal
geplante und verwirklichen gang und
deswegen das sind zwei welten die
aufeinander prallen
eine reale lage in der wir heute leben
müssen der ukraine herr konto kann das
überhaupt falsch sein wenn sich zwei
sportler zwei männer zwei menschen
umarmt gleich welcher nationalität sie
gerade sind sie haben gerade sport
wettkampf gegeneinander geführt und
umarmen sich danach kann das falsch sein
nein natürlich nicht ich meine ich kenne
den fall nicht ich weiß auch nicht wie
die reaktion darauf war aber man uns
nicht vergessen
man muss nicht vergessen dass die nerven
ja ziemlich land sind jetzt gerade in
ukraine dass das dass russland als land
gar nicht teilnehmen darf auf die
olympiade war sein verhalten auch wegen
doping und so schlecht war das russische
sportler da sozusagen als freiberufler
teilgenommen haben heute hätten wir das
halt ich kann die lage viele martina
erlebt ja wer mir wir müssen aus der
vergangenheit auch er nämlich sehr genau
aus den zeiten der kelten des kalten
krieges das sport sehr oft in die
politik einbezogen wird das ist
vielleicht schon traurig habe es so so
ich hätte nichts dagegen wenn eine
ukrainische russische sporne sich
umarmen das für dich auch den geist der
menschen spiele aber ich verstehe es
auch wenn das vielleicht haben vor allem
auf
und keine emotionen gibt paul ronzheimer
wenn wir über die menschen sprechen da
auf den beiden seiten und jetzt gerade
anhand dieses so beeindruckenden fotos
dieser beeindruckende geschichte aus
peking
lassen sich die menschen auf beiden
seiten oder würde man sich sofort in die
arme fallen wenn die truppen dort
abziehen würden
nein die menschen hassen sich nicht ich
sehe dass insbesondere an vitali
klitschko den ich viel begleitet habe
der hat einen hintergrund in russland
und der ukraine und so geht es vielen
menschen hier und auch wenn wir an der
front unterwegs sind dann höre ich von
leuten die beschossen werden von der
separatisten seite oder von der
russischen seite von der russischen
armee seite das sie dann in donetsk also
bei den separatisten anrufen weil sie da
freunde haben also gerade hier wo ich
gerade stehe sind die familien getrennt
worden durch diese front und ich glaube
wir brauchen mehr bilder von ukrainern
und russen die sich umarmen aber was wir
auch brauchen und das verstört mich ist
das die menschen aufstehen gegen die
politik putins denn man muss einen
unterschied machen zwischen den menschen
und der politik und wir haben gesehen
dass es weder in europa noch in den usa
oder in russland demonstrationen gibt
für den frieden diese demonstration da
2003 gegen den irak krieg gegeben da
waren millionen auf der straße und jetzt
und das frustriert hier viele ukraine
sehen wir kaum unterstellt warum ist das
so herr stegner warum ist das so warum
begab sich am wochenende wir haben hier
immer den demo samstag in berlin da
kommen alle möglichen kleinen gruppen
zusammen warum haben wir nicht eine
massive große demonstration vor der
russischen botschaft
ich glaube dass die menschen frieden
wollen und dass sie deswegen die
unterstützt die das unterstützen was
momentan stattfindet nämlich das mit
allen diplomatischen wegen versucht wird
zu
dafür zu sorgen dass beim frieden bleibt
und sollte sich das ändern können sie
ganz sicher sein dass ganz viele
menschen auf dem straßen wären aber da
doch diplomatie zu demonstrieren dass
die diplomatie wird schon von den
fahrten gemacht von denen verhandeln und
übrigens gute außenpolitik ist sowohl
werte geleitet als auch realitätsbezogen
dass man ich muss man dann auch immer
dazu bei all dem hinzufügen und deswegen
weil die frage ja vorhin war
wer da sehr viel fern ist man kann dann
kann sie ihren für die position im monat
weil die beiden nicht kenne kann ich ja
vorher nicht gesagt eine dumme frage mit
der nato ich habe eine frage die nicht
auf der tagesordnung steht krieg zu
führen wäre das dümmste was man tun
könnte und ein krieg hat nur verlierer
insbesondere die zivilbevölkerung und
deswegen müssen all die fragen gelöst
wenn er helfen auch nicht vergleichen
mit chamberlain und der zeit von hitler
wir haben jetzt andere verhältnisse und
wir müssen zu recht kommt übrigens mit
ländern die unsere werte nicht teilen
das gilt ja nicht nur verrückt es anders
geht na wo die olympiahalle stattfindet
auch bei taiwan oder hongkong gibt es
durchaus deutliche worte aber kein
mensch schickt dort waffen hin um zu
weil er glaubt die satzung wird besser
mit christian trotzdem noch meine
nachbarn mit der diplomatie zum erfolg
zu kommen das unterstützen die menschen
auch ja alle umfragen zeigen ich habe
mir noch in deutschland bei dem was sie
sagen die fachleute die regeln das schon
gerade weil meine eindruck entstanden
bisschen dass wenn es jetzt
demonstrationen gäbe dass aus ihrer
sicht das nochmal öl ins feuer gießen
würde das wäre doch habe eine massive
solidaritätsbekundung für herrn melnik
nein das würde nicht überall die
menschen das würde nicht nur den scheuer
gießen sondern ganz im gegenteil alle
umfragen sagen uns dass die menschen
angst haben vor klickt dass sie das
nicht wollen dass sie übrigens
vielleicht auch deswegen dagegen sind
und dass mit waffen noch zu verstärken
weil das konnte nicht militärisch gelöst
werden können sondern musste damals
haben hier offenkundig unterschiedliche
meinungen und die haben ja auch bei
anderen dingen und von der konsum das
gesagt will ich ihnen sagen ja natürlich
können wir die gaspipeline streiten und
sie wäre auf dem tisch logischerweise
wenn der fall käme umgekehrt sind
natürlich auch die amerikaner
zweitgrößte öl
ist der öllieferant nach kanada ist
russland an amerika also auch da gehen
und hat ist und wo man unterschiedlicher
meinung sein kann wir wollen uns das
nicht gegenseitig um die ohren hauen
sondern einfach nur sagen ich glaube es
muss eine diplomatische lösung des
konflikts geben eine andere kann ist
nicht geben wir hätten nur auf
schlussrunde bei bild bei den richtigen
fragen bitte jeder einsatz beginnen mit
den ski erleben wir in einer woche am
nächsten sonntag an dieser stelle krieg
vor einer woche habe ich noch nein
gesagt jetzt denke ich dass es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist herr stegner
ich hoffe mein herr kornblum
ich weiß es nicht aber ich würde eher
sagen ja als nein und vor allem war die
europäer schwach gewesen sind eher wenig
also wenn deutschland nicht handelt wenn
die sanktionen nicht angeführt sind wenn
die waffe nicht geliefert werden dann
ist der krieg durchaus möglich paul dein
schlusswort von der front
ich habe lange nicht mehr gebetet aber
in diesen tagen und in diesen stunden
bild sich dass der krieg nicht kommt das
tue ich auch dem schließe ich mich an
und danke ihnen für diese diskussion
hierbei bild die richtigen fragen mit
der meldung kein kondom betreibt stegner
sergey lagodinsky und von der front
alles gute die ab nächsten sonntag
simply zurück 22 45
[Musik]